COULD BE AN IMPORTANT UPDATE
FROM CLARK COUNTY.
>> VERY IMPORTANT INDEED, ERIN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN SPECIAL
CORRESPONDENT JAMIE GANGLE RIGHT
NOW.
AUDIE CORNISH, CNN ANCHOR AND
CORRESPONDENT AND MARK PRESTON,
CNN SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST,
MARK, IT'S INTERESTING, SEVERAL
TRUMP-BACKED CANDIDATES LOST
SOME KEY RACES LAST NIGHT.
WHAT'S YOUR ANALYSIS?
OTHER TRUMP-BACKED CANDIDATES
ARE TRAILING EVEN AS WE SPEAK
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT'S YOUR ANALYSIS OF HOW BAD
A TIME THIS WAS FOR TRUMP?
>> I MEAN, IT WAS TERRIBLE.
WE HAD THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS TIME YESTERDAY ABOUT WOULD
HE TAKE CREDIT OR WOULD HE TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY?
AND HE'S CLEARLY NOT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY.
IN FACT, WHAT WAS TELLING LAST
NIGHT, TWO TELL, FIRST TELL WAS
WHEN HE GAVE HIS SPEECH DOWN AT
MAR-A-LAGO BECAUSE HE HAD A
VICTORY PARTY EVEN THOUGH HE
WASN'T ON THE BALLOT BUT THAT'S
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT WHEN HE GAVE A VICTORY
SPEECH, HE TURNED TO THE ALABAMA
SENATE CANDIDATE WHO WAS GOING
TO WIN NO MATTER WHAT AND USED
THAT AS AN EXAM MANY OF SOMEBODY
WHO HE ENDORSED, YOU KNOW, TO,
YOU KNOW, WIN THE SEAT IN
ALABAMA WHICH IS LIKE GOING TO
ALASKA AND, YOU KNOW, ENDORSING
SNOW, RIGHT?
I MEAN IT'S THERE.
IT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE SECOND BIG TELL J.D. VANCE
IN OHIO WHEN HE WAS THANKING
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR HELP AND
FOR -- EVERYBODY, I MEAN, IN
FACT, IF WE HAD LISTENED TO IT,
THE FOUR OF US MAY HAVE BEEN ON
THE LIST SOMEWHERE.
WHO WAS NOT ON THE LIST?
DONALD TRUMP.
>> HE MENTIONED ABOUT 30 NAMES.
>> RIGHT.
>> HE DIDN'T MENTION DONALD
TRUMP.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW --
>> HE WAS A TRUMP BACKER.
>> HE WAS, HE WAS AND ONE THING
THIS MADE ME THINK OF, THERE WAS
SO MUCH CONVERSATION ABOUT WHERE
BIDEN NEEDED TO BE AND IF IT WAS
A HURT OR A HELP FOR BIDEN TO
STAND NEXT TO A CANDIDATE.
I THINK PEOPLE MAY AGAIN REVIEW
WHERE TRUMP WAS AND WHETHER OR
NOT IT HURT OR HELP.
IN PENNSYLVANIA BRINGING MEHMET
OZ ON STAGE WITH DOUG MASTRIANO,
A CANDIDATE WHO WAS VERY MUCH
STRUGGLING AND HAD BEEN, YOU
KNOW, PRETTY WELL DEFINED BY HIS
RIVAL IN ADS, I DON'T THINK THAT
HELPED OZ.
AND I THINK PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
REALLY BE SCRUTINIZING WHERE
TRUMP IS HELPFUL AND IF IT'S NOT
IN PURPLE AND SWING STATES,
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> CERTAINLY IS.
JAMIE, WE KNOW TRUMP BASED 0EN
THAT REPORTING IS FUMING RIGHT
NOW OVER THE RESULTS AT LEAST SO
FAR AND HE'S ALSO FUMING THAT
THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA WAS
RE-ELECTED.
NOT JUST RE-ELECTED BUT BIG TIME
RON DeSANTIS AND TRUMP IS NO BIG
FAN.
YOU MADE FUN OF HIM JUST THE
OTHER NIGHT.
SO YOU'VE BEEN TALKING TO
REPUBLICANS.
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU?
>> SO, YOU KNOW, TO MARK'S
POINT, AUDIE'S POINT, YESTERDAY
WAS A BAD DAY FOR DONALD TRUMP.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
IT ALSO, BY THE WAY, WAS NOT A
GREAT DAY FOR KEVIN McCARTHY WHO
IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S GOING
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO TAKE
THE HOUSE, BUT IF IT IS A SLIM
MARGIN, HE'S GOING TO HAVE A
TRICKY PATH NAVIGATING IT WITH
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS BUT TO GO
BACK TO DONALD TRUMP, LOOK, WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN TO HIM?
HE IS NEVER GOING TO TAKE THE
BLAME.
HE'S GOING TO SAY, OH, THEY WERE
WEAK CANDIDATES, NOT MY FAULT.
HE'LL ALWAYS TAKE THE CREDIT.
HE'LL LOOK AT HIS POLLS, HIS
RATINGS AS HE LIKES TO CALL
THEM, BUT TRUMP NEVER ADMITS
DEFEAT.
I DO NOT THINK TALKING TO MY
SOURCES THAT THIS WILL IN ANY
WAY CHANGE.
WE ASSUME THAT IN THE NEXT WEEK
OR TWO, MAYBE THE 15th, HE IS
GOING TO ANNOUNCE THAT HE'S
RUNNING.
EVERYBODY I SPOKE TO IN TRUMP
WORLD, AND REPUBLICAN SOURCES,
SAY THEY EXPECT HIM TO GO AHEAD
FULL STEAM.
I WILL SAY IT DOES CHANGE, I
THINK, THE DYNAMICS FOR GOP
PRESIDENTIAL HOPEFULS.
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE GOTTEN
IN THE RACE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
SECOND LOOK, ESPECIALLY SINCE
THEY ARE SEEING THAT THERE ARE
REPUBLICAN VOTERS OUT THERE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO WANT TO
MOVE ON FROM DONALD TRUMP.
>> YEAH, GOOD POINT, INDEED.
YOU KNOW, MARK, THE GEORGIA
SENATE RACE WHICH IS SO, SO
IMPORTANT IS GOING TO A RUNOFF
RIGHT NOW IN EARLY DECEMBER, I
THINK DECEMBER 6th THERE WILL BE
A RUNOFF ELECTION.
YOU GOT SOME NEW REPORTING ON
HOW THE WALKER CAMPAIGN,
HERSCHEL WALKER CAMPAIGN IS
PREPARING FOR THIS.
>> SO RIGHT NOW, WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TOLD, JUST IN THE LAST HOUR OR
SO I TALKED TO THE WALKER
CAMPAIGN, WE ARE SEEING THE
REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT
COALESCE VERY QUICKLY BEHIND
WALKER AND, OF COURSE, YOU WOULD
EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN BUT
PERHAPS EVEN QUICKER, GIVEN
WHAT'S AT STAKE RIGHT NOW WHICH
IS POTENTIALLY CONTROL OF THE
SENATE AND WHAT LITTLE OF JOE
BIDEN'S AGENDA MAY OR MAY NOT
GET THROUGH IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS BUT TOLD TED CRUZ WILL
BE THE FIRST SENATOR WE'LL SEE
TOMORROW AND ARRIVE AND CAMPAIGN
FOR WALKER.
HE'LL BE ONE OF MANY OVER THE
NEXT MONTH.
"TO SEE A LOT OF REPUBLICAN
SENATORS DOWN THERE.
WHAT WAS INTERESTING WITH THE
WALKER CAMPAIGN AND WHAT THEY
TOLD ME A SHORT TIME AGO THEY
SAID IT WAS SMART THAT JOE BIDEN
DIDN'T COME INTO GEORGIA.
IT WAS A VERY SMART MOVE ON THE
WARNOCK CAMPAIGN BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO TIE HIM AS TIGHT
AS THEY WANTED TO.
WHAT WE SHOULD EXPECT IN THE
NEXT THROUGH OR FOUR WEEKS IS
WE'LL SEE AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT
OF EXPOSURE JUST ON WARNOCK
HIMSELF AND HOW CONTROL OF THE
SENATE, THE CONTROL OF THE
REPUBLICAN CONSERVATIVE AGENDA
OR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF ONE IS
GOING TO REST ON THIS RACE, ONE
THING ABOUT DeSANTIS BECAUSE I
DO THINK IT'S INTERESTING AND IN
SOME WAYS SAD, DeSANTIS A HUGE
WINNER, BUT DeSANTIS HAS A
HURRICANE COMING INTO FLORIDA
RIGHT NOW, WHICH IS AWFUL BUT
YOU CAN -- HE CAN USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW LEADERSHIP
SKILLS COMING OFF OF JUST AN
AMAZING NIGHT THAT HE HAD.
>> OR THE FLIP SIDE IS THAT'S
WHY PEOPLE RESPOND TO HIM
BECAUSE FUNDAMENTALLY HE DOES
TRY TO DO THE JOB OF GOVERNING
AND I THINK WHILE THIS WASN'T A
REFERENDUM ON TRUMP IN THE WAY
PEOPLE EXPECTED IT WAS A
REFERENDUM ON TRUMPISM.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BE THAT
KIND OF CANDIDATE?